hi everybody my name is scott mansfield
i'm a senior software engineer on the AV
cache team at netflix and i'm here to
talk to you about the hidden micro
service it's our nickname for the
caching layer to be clear before I start
this has nothing to do with the open
connects CDN which some people also
refer to as a cache that's a really cool
interesting deep concept all on its own
it's not what we're talking about this
is just the Amazon Web Services cloud
caching layer so you just signed up for
Netflix good decision you get home the
end of the day you turn on your TV
you open the Netflix app you need to
sign in with your brand-new account you
choose your profile and naturally your
name is tester like everybody else you
asks you to pick a few titles that
you've liked before or maybe ones that
you've seen so you pick a few keep going
it tells you it's personalizing your
experience for you so it's building a
brand new homepage just for you and
there you are
you get there you have house of cards
making a murder which is a fantastic
documentary you could do a search for
Tom Hanks watch Forrest Gump for the
millionth time but you settle on narcos
this says season 2 coming September 2nd
it's already out in case anybody is
excited about that show you can go watch
season 2 you're watching the first
episode you get to the part where he
tells the gardener llamo Pablo Emilio
Escobar's guy Vidya and he tells him
Plata o Plomo
and you're so impressed by this line you
need to go rate this show five stars and
you've him just showing all of your
friends all the favorite parts of all
you of your episodes and we're keeping
track so any guesses on how long we have
to capture your attention before you go
off and do something else guesses [ __ ]
okay okay a little bit short it's about
90 seconds
so the faster the smoother the better
the experience that you have the more
likely we are to keep your attention and
keep you watching Netflix and part of
the way we do that is by caching things
on the server side so let's take a look
in that experience that you just saw
what things caches touch you're signing
up logging in choosing a profile picking
like videos the personalization process
which we'll look at in a little bit more
detail later loading the homepage itself
scrolling through the homepage any a be
test allocations that might be on your
profile and even the video image
selection the boxart that you're seeing
and there's a whole mess of other things
even beyond that and if you look there's
a bunch of these have multiple caches
involved in the backend
put another way this is what a typical
homepage request looks like this is the
output from our request facing system so
the request comes in from the left side
and goes all the way down to the right
if you look at those leaf nodes on the
right there's maybe half a dozen that
are not an easy cash node so I've talked
about it
I mentioned it let's talk a little bit
about EB cache
it stands for ephemeral volatile cash
it's a key value store that we run
that's optimized for running on Amazon
Web Services and tuned for Netflix
specific use cases it's a distributed
sharded and replicated store and that
replication is tunable both within a
single region and across multiple
different regions it's based on memcache
two highly resilient to failure because
AWS is a highly dynamic environment one
of my colleagues actually called AWS
chaos monkey as a service which is
pretty accurate all credit to him for
that but they actually kill more of our
instances than the chaos monkey does
it's topology aware network topology
aware for faster access as linearly
scalable we can scale out the server
side as much as we need to to handle the
traffic and it has seamless deployments
for our internal customers so why do we
want to optimize for AWS like I said
it's highly dynamic but what does that
mean well instances can up and disappear
at any time zones can fail entire
regions can become unstable for any one
of a variety of reasons the network
itself is lossy and customer requests
can actually bounce between multiple
different regions of the same session
and the simple fact of life is that
failures happen and we have to be ready
for them and we test them all the time
so that we are ready so I'll give you a
sense of scale for Evi cache use of
Netflix we hold hundreds of terabytes of
data and cache we do trillions of
operations per day hold tens of billions
of items do millions of operations per
second millions of cross region
replications per second between two
different regions which we'll look at in
more detail later we have thousands of
servers it's more than ten thousand but
not quite enough to call it like tens of
thousands we have hundreds of instances
for cluster up to hundreds hundreds of
service clients that are potentially
connecting to a single cluster it tens
of distinct clusters for different use
cases they're tuned differently or have
different setups we operate across three
regions and we do this with four
engineers
yeah so let's take a look at just like a
single app box and a single server box
how they talk to each other or just what
the setup looks like there's an
application running on our cloud
somewhere the likely path is that
they're consuming somebody else's
service client that library would then
consume our Evie cache client library
and this is a Java client library it's a
jar that we've end the server side has
memcache D or what looks like memcache D
and prana which is a sidecar it's
written in Java it's used for people who
are running applications that are not
based in Java it hooks into the rest of
the Netflix ecosystem so we can report
metrics and and register with our
service discovery system their client
talks directly to memcache T there's a
TCP connection between the two the
sidecar will register with our service
discovery and the client can pull that
information in order to find the server
so one client with a whole Evie cache
cluster here if you look there's three
different availability zones and there's
this dotted line around these boxes
that's a whole copy of data so in this
picture we have three whole copies of
data one per availability zone and the
client has a connection to all of these
separately if we have many clients all
the clients have a connection to all the
boxes so this forms what's called a
complete bipartite graph so all clients
connected to all servers no clients
connected to each other and no servers
are actually talking to each other so
for reading relatively simple we try the
closest one first and there's a couple
backup paths in case that one doesn't
work out if it's a brand new instance if
it just died or it's having network
problems or any one of a number of
failures that can happen we can try a
different node a writing is a little bit
more interesting the client writes to
all three and that's how we have
multiple different copies
all clients would be writing to all the
different places that they need to write
data so we're gonna take a look at a few
different use cases going from simple to
complex this one's fairly
straightforward it's a pretty common use
case so if you have a relatively slow
service in a relatively fast cache you
can try the cache first and look in the
service layer so if the application
requests some data from the client
library here we try Eevee cache client
first and if it's not there we can go to
the service which will go to its
database typically Cassandra for us and
then the service itself is responsible
for writing back into the cache before
or asynchronously as it returns the data
the second one transient data store so
thinks things like your playback session
as it's going on we want to keep track
of how you're doing and over time we
have multiple different applications
talk to the cache you might have one
start up your session another one update
your session then do a session roll-up
at the very end have you notice there's
no database in this picture it's just
the cache there this is a lot more
interesting to me this is our largest
footprint really of caches
it's actually the primary storage
mechanism for data so we have these
really large scale pre compute systems
that run overnight every day to compute
a brand-new home page for every profile
of every user it's quite a lot of
computation and it's quite a lot of data
and what they do is they just write it
into an e be cache cluster and the
online services are reading from this
not worrying about what time anything
was written we have a pretty strong
culture of fall back so you don't have
to worry so much about data not quite
being there all the time so the whole
picture looks like this we have a set of
offline services writing in the cache so
I have online services reading and the
cache acts as this buffer between the
two or a gateway or many other words you
could use for it so this is our
personalization data this is even more
interesting we have some things that are
very high volume and also need to be
very high availability so thank you I
strings where if you don't
them the user experience is pretty bad
because it has no words on it they would
have an in-memory cache and then if that
doesn't have the data or they could do a
background refresh from evie cache if it
doesn't have the data they could reach
out to give you cash it does if it does
they could do a background refresh so
think about whenever we're going into
our peak during the day we need to scale
up some servers and they all want to get
this data they'll be pulling it from UV
cache and there's another process that
is asynchronously computing the latest
package and publishing it to the cache
and beyond that they could even go
further and have a service that owns
this data or the database behind it but
most people have actually found this to
be optional because the uptime of the
evie cache clusters is so good that they
don't worry about it so we've been
looking at maybe 10,000 feet let's take
a step back let's go to 3050 and take a
look at what I call pipeline of
personalization so when you compute a
new homepage it's not just one step
there's many different steps involved
with different algorithms doing
different things you would have one say
just compute a publishing into an Eevee
cache clustered its data sources or
something that we're not involved with
may be offline hive or other data
sources and then maybe a compute B you
might have a see that depends on these
two and a D and maybe an e and this
forms a dag of data dependencies for our
personalization process all this happens
offline and online services don't just
pull the last output they might pick and
choose from different parts of this in
order to provide the experience that
they need so online one pull from A
through D and online to could pulls from
a different set
so the polyglot story at Netflix is an
interesting one it's a point of
discussion right now even but our team
as a somewhat central service has
decided to go ahead and solve this in
our own way our old world or current
world really is a Java app and our Java
client that's pretty straightforward is
what you've already seen but other
people actually run our prana sidecar as
well so we have an HTTP like a REST API
that runs on box that people can use to
access the cache and we've made that
remote as well so we have a remote HTTP
API and even an experimental memcache D
protocol API that we've been working on
with a couple of our partner teams
internally this is still an area of
active development for us so I don't
really have any more detail on it right
now if you want to know more you can
talk to me at the booth upstairs
afterwards there's some extra things on
top of all the things that I've shown
you so far that make the product work at
Netflix scale the main one is our cross
region global replication we also do
cache warming for faster deployments we
have secondary indexing for point
queries for debugging and we have a
consistency checker that provides
metrics on how consistent the caches are
now all of this is powered by mutation
metadata flowing through a Kafka cluster
so we'll take a look at replication and
the cache forming first so replication
we have two regions here we actually
operate out of three so this goes
between like every pair but I'll just
show you these two we have an app and
region a and an app and region B and we
have a cache in region a that we want to
match the cache in region B so in a an
app could mutate that cache and
asynchronously send metadata about that
mutation into Kafka we have an app we
call our replication relay it pulls that
data out of Kafka and can optionally
pull the data if it needs it out of the
and write it across the cross region
linked to what we call a replication
proxy which does that operation on
behalf of the app in region a in the
cache and region B and then the app in
region B can see that change and of
course this goes both directions or
every which way between all different
regions a cache warming this is our
steady state so you've seen this before
without the Kafka button this heart in
our steady state we're writing to one
cache say we want to double it is two
nodes right now we want four but we can
bring up a second one in parallel that's
double the size and start writing to it
immediately we bring up a cache warming
app that pulls that metadata stream from
Kafka can read the data from the old one
and write it into the new one until the
new one looks like the old one
and we can tear down the cache warmer
tear down the old one well send reads
the new one first then tear down the old
one and win our new steady state and
very recent modifications or updates to
memcache D itself have actually made it
possible for us to do this without the
Kafka box on here but we're still
figuring out how to roll that on the
production this is all the code that our
clients need to use in order to actually
take advantage of all of that complexity
I've just shown you all they need to do
is make a client set get delete touch
etc anything that you might think to do
on a memcache D server that's all our
clients need to do internally
so let's switch gears a little bit I've
been working well I've been showing you
all of this higher level design work how
the caches operate in the larger
environment let's take a deeper dive
into the server side so this is a new
server for us and we just were at the
tail end of rolling this out to the
places that it's required
it's a project we call Minetta his name
Minetta after the goddess of memory and
the protectress of funds for Juno as an
evolution of our server to put some data
on disk is a cost optimization project
for us and it's lowering our cost now
but also lowering the rate of increase
of our cost in the future as we gain
more members this is pretty important
for us because we actually track the
cost per stream start it's a metric that
our finance team tracks and something
that is highly correlated if we change
that will be helpful in the future and
it takes advantage of our global request
patterns that we have across multiple
different regions so our old server
you've already seen
it's just memcache D and prana it's not
very exciting all the data stored in RAM
this is very expensive relatively
speaking compared to disk the late last
year Netflix as a company changed their
architecture so changed our architecture
to be n plus one across three different
regions meaning that any one region
could go down at any time and we would
be okay by shifting traffic to the other
two any member can be served equally
well from any region in addition at the
beginning of this calendar year we
launched in 130 new countries at the
same time which just added more data on
to the pilot so how do we optimize this
well we can target those personalization
pre compute use cases that you saw
before our global data means many copies
so that picture that you saw with three
copies is actually nine globally because
it's three in one region three in each
region times three
nine copies but our hacked our access
patterns are very heavily region
oriented if you're watching Netflix in
California you are hitting the US west
to region the likelihood that we see
your traffic go to EU West one or or Us
East one the other two regions that we
operate out of is extremely low so in
one region our hot data is very hot and
our cold data is very cold it will keep
the hot data and RAM and the cold data
on disk and we can size the RAM for the
working set and size the SSD for the
whole data set
what was our new server look like it
adds a couple of new processes there's
one called rent and another called
mnemonic we're still running memcache D
the server now is a dynamic l1 l2 cache
which allows it to adapt to the needs of
the application at anytime without
worrying about very strictly segregating
data and all three of these processes
are running the same protocol so we can
use the same debugging tools or same
load generation tools to test any one of
them so rent here is the proxy taking
external connections and holding open
connections to the internal processes
memcache D and mnemonic are l1 and l2
we'll take a look at ren first take a
look at mnemonic see the whole thing
together and we'll take a look at some
performance numbers which is probably
the most exciting part for me so any go
developers in the audience yes okay this
is a go project you can go get it it's
actually a public github repo under the
Netflix org so yeah have fun with that
it's a high performance wire compatible
memcache D proxy and server it's a
transparent change to our clients it's
written in go mostly for its concurrency
primitives but also because it's
relatively fast for developers to get up
and running in to write new code and
it's very fast and it's running in
production its purpose is to manage the
l1 and l2 relationship on a single box
and before the project even started we
had caches that had tens of thousands of
concurrent connections reading and
writing that was a requirement for this
process from the very beginning so
taking a better look at the insides of
it it's a modular software project what
you see on github is actually what we're
running in production it's not fake it
manages the connections coming in the
request orchestration between l1 and l2
communicating to the backends it even
includes our own homegrown metrics
library which might make some of you
cringe but nothing really fit our needs
in the NGO world because we have to
integrate with our Atlas back-end and
Netflix it includes multiple
orchestrators reasons for which will
become apparent when we look at the
whole thing together and it includes
this feature which we call parallel
locking so any one server can have many
parallel requests happening at the exact
same time but no one key will have two
concurrent modifications which allows us
to keep data integrity and keep l1 and
l2 consistent so mnemonic this is our l2
piece I say open source soon with air
quotes because I don't really have a
timeline for you but I want to get it
open source we'll see this is our SSD
backed storage solution it reuses some
of the rent code to do the heavy lifting
for memcache T protocol parsing and
connection management but its main
purpose is to map those memcache the
operations into rocks DB operations so
in the bottom you can see rocks DV the
request here would come in on top of
this diagram run through the code that
you've already seen in whren and through
a shim to get into the c++ world into
our mnemonic core library which then
uses the rocks DB library underneath to
store the data on disk
we chose rocks TV for a few different
reasons mostly because when you write to
rocks DB it writes directly into an
in-memory buffer which then is
asynchronously flushed on a disk in
these static files so it's fast to write
and fast to read so how do we use it
specifically we use FIFO compaction
which isn't really compacting anything
at all it's just this FIFO queue of
files on disk it's linearly
written in terms of time so more recent
files coming at the front of the queue
and older files will just get deleted if
yet weep in the bloom filters and
indices in memory for quick access or
misses as the case may be which does
trade some l1 space but it makes our l2
much faster which is great for us and we
have many rocks tb7 like separate rocks
TV instances per box so that we can
further decrease the latency this is
great for our pre compute use cases but
we're still working on figuring out how
to do this for much for more
heterogeneous data so if we have very
fast-moving data next to very slow very
fast changing data next to very slow
changing data the fast changing data can
write enough data on disk to actually
push the slow ones off the end of the
FIFO queue and then we've lost something
which is not great so we're working on
this still the whole thing together is a
little bit more complex
we run multiple different open ports in
production for different use cases per
server so we have these servers already
serving all of that personalization data
before remember that pipeline of
personalization all those green Eevee
cache nodes were this server we have two
ports one for standard access which is
highly dynamic access or actively
managed data and then we have an async
batch port well it's really a batch port
it's not a sink but it's for people who
are writing data in that won't
necessarily be used anytime soon and
it'll keep the working set hot so that
we don't end up blowing away our l1 when
we're computing our personalization
stuff okay the slide I've been waiting
for so this is performance in production
for our most heavily loaded cache that
is using Minetta right now I measured
both at the peak like the three hours of
peak for us and the three hours in the
trough for us all the different Layton
sees and percentiles and things so
given all the complexity that we've
added to this you might think that it's
really slow but taking a look at the
gets our average latency is around two
hundred and thirty microseconds on the
server side and you can see the
percentiles here the higher ones get a
little high because it's got go as a
garbage collected language but that's
okay with us the 99th is really really
great for us and in the trough it's even
faster and the sets are also we're very
happy with this 367 microseconds average
and like I said you can see the rest of
the percentiles there but these are all
great for us so if we look at client
side Layton sees the network in AWS adds
maybe 250 to 500 microseconds and most
people expect an answer out of us in
under a millisecond almost all the time
okay I told you this is a cost
optimization project any guesses highest
percentage savings we saw in a single
cluster one thousand percent kind of
impossible
10% a little low okay is about 70% cost
savings on a single cluster just because
we noticed that we have this small hot
set and a really large cold dataset and
this project has been a really great one
for us and we're just nearing the end of
rolling it out
so yeah huge success for us all these
things that you've seen not all of them
sorry mnemonic we've had the air quotes
around it
evie cache the Java client library is
open source and that REST API that I
mentioned earlier is also in that same
repository and the rent code itself is
also open source on the netflix github
repo so you can go check those out and
that's all I have
okay I'll take any questions if anybody
once yes I wasn't the engineer that
sorry the question was the decision tree
to get to rocks dB
I wasn't the engineer who made the
decision specifically to go with rocks
DB but generally it was the fastest it
worked for our use case yeah I have to
think about it a little bit more you can
I'll be at the booth after this for a
couple hours so please come find me yes
all right have we considered using
Couchbase no not really
we've talked to them before we're happy
with our homegrown solution that's
working really well for us if we need to
customize it in any way we can just turn
around and modify our code and get a new
candidate jar out the same day I don't
believe that would be a good process for
Couchbase so I mean I haven't like gone
into deep talks with them but we're
happy with where we are and I don't
think that we would have been able to do
something like the monitor projects
directly with them yes
right so have we found any limitations
with the commands that are available in
the memcache D protocol not really a lot
of our data is organized by user or
profile or something like that most of
the time people just want to get the
whole piece of data there's not very
many use cases where they just want like
the one array element so it's not really
necessary
any other questions yes time scale for
this project you mean the Minetta
project right the time scale I started
dabbling and go about a year ago and
started hacking on rent
maybe November if I had convinced my
teammates earlier this year that it was
a good idea to do this project in this
manner and we are basically done rolling
it out into production for the largest
use cases right now so about a year
total yeah follow up
so how did I convince my teammates to
use go kind of like because we're not in
the paved path anymore it's not too hard
when you make a proof of concept that's
already running fast right off the bat
so that's what I said like it's fast
when it's compiled I had a relatively
dumb like text protocol based version
that was already running you know in the
hundreds of thousands of RPS fairly
easily so from there we don't we don't
even run that fast I need one server
from there we can work out how to make
it function on the server we already had
memcache D which was essentially a
binary blob to us we already were kind
of off the paved path so it didn't
really scare us so much plus my
teammates have been converted I guess to
the religion of go at this point they
seem to like the language is there any
other questions anybody up top anything
yeah okay do the management asked us to
do this to save money not directly
engineers at Netflix tend to have a lot
of context about how the business is
doing and where it's going and what the
needs are so as a team we've looked at
what our needs were and saw this
opportunity for an optimization so we
decided to just go for it
and you know not only do we have to
convince ourselves this is a good idea
we have to go to all these people whose
data we're storing and tell them hey
we're gonna change this out from under
you I hope you're ok with that
and they generally are so it was driven
mostly by the engineers but we had
backup as we were pitching
this idea started as a side project
became my main project just because we
decided it was a higher priority
anything else yes I'm sorry I can't hear
you can you speak up please
okay I probably didn't explain that
extremely well is the first time I
presented that slide publicly so our
personalization project process ends up
creating an ad hoc data dependency dag
but it's not any formalized like dag
that exists anywhere in any form other
than in engineers minds of this is my
dependency so when they're writing the
data out their process writes into an
Eevee cache cluster and those Eevee
cache clusters are in discovery in the
service discovery system and anybody can
find them at any time so that's I'm not
sure if I answered your question yeah so
anybody who wants to talk to Eevee cache
would use the Eureka system in order to
to access them does that answer your
question
well in that in that diagram there was
these like single green like database
looking things that was meant to
represent a whole cluster and that's
actually a globally replicated charted
cluster I saw another yes and he plans
to extend to other cloud providers it's
open source
we accept patches pull requests not
really we our team is focused on solving
Netflix problems we have it an open
source in the hopes that it helps other
people solve their problems
it's not a primary goal for us to
support the open source as an open
source thing like but it should be
useful to some people anything else up
top nothing ok I think that's it